Vsauce, are you leaning back right now?
Of course you're not. But you will be soon,
because a new episode of Vsauce Leanback
has just been released and to start it,
click the link at the top of
this video's description. This week's topic is
really fun. It's a menagerie of awesome
videos from producers
all over YouTube with the atmosphere
of Earth as our rough guide.
We're going to begin way down here,
in this part of the atmosphere, the troposphere,
which is where most weather occurs
and where we live.
And then we'll move up into the
stratosphere and beyond to the
mysterious mesosphere
and then the gigantic thermosphere where
space shuttles roam.
And even though they said it couldn't be done,
we will be discussing the exosphere
today.
So what are you waiting for? Click the link
at the top of this video's description to
begin autoplay mode and let
each video segment start one after the
other. So all you have to do is lean back
and let the information hit you in the face.
I'll see you soon
in the lean back.
And as always,
thanks for watching.